so let me first by start by saying I saw
this last night and I had a blast oh
great this is a lot of fun and
disturbing and I smiled in it yeah it
really is
and I'm just gonna say that you have
forever changed me I will never return a
purse that I lined on the subway never
give it to lost property yeah
well 100% I'll give it's the nearest
homeless person on the street I think
either one right nobody so I've a
million things I want to talk about but
first thing is that it's so unusual to
have this story with all women it's it's
refreshing and it's unique and it's a
twist on the trope that you normally see
yeah we thought so yeah that that's one
of the reasons I did it I mean I didn't
write the script I rewrote the script
it's written by a Hollywood writer
called ray Wright who has done some
horror films I think yeah but when I was
at a script with her okay stalker movie
I'm not sure to add that but then this
little handbag really kind of gripped me
I thought I want that handbag you know
and I want to go where the handbag goes
you know when the that turned out to be
17 of the handbags in Greta's apartment
I thought okay that is clever okay now I
mean you know so I thought okay and
that's between women which was great you
know you don't have a you don't have an
evil smelling kind of yeah Perkins kind
of dude you know you know with bad
clothes and some other obsession you
don't have that here you have actually a
mother you know with an obsession but
it's a difference she's sophisticated
she's kind of she plays the piano she
speaks French she does everything that
you'd wish you know a random encounter
in a subway or in a gallery or somewhere
in the street to be oh this lovely
person I met this lovely person she's my
new friend you like I think so
I thought that was interesting and you
know I basically then thought okay I'll
just see how far I can push this you
know into what realms of grotesquerie in
what realms of you know kind of Atlantis
you know you would there's a great bit
where Isabelle is dancing in the house
in the house and I was thinking to
myself was just a direct calm
titian with Oscar Isaac dancing in ex
machina because apply gifts that go
around with like characters dancing okay
no I was fortunate with the music really
I mean I mean because because music is a
theme for her character yeah she plays
the lists on the liebestraum you know
it's just kind of a sickly sweet kind of
music it's kind of like the Michael
Buble of classical music isn't it you
know if you don't mind me saying that
sorry but it's I'm then wench when Steve
the Steven ray character came to the
apartment she needed to pull up that
Chopin very loud so I chose that piece
of Chopin very carefully and when we
came to do that scene I said Isabelle
can we do this is a ballet you know can
we try and do it as a dance so she's
dancing to the music as she's teasing
him really you know as the kind of
narcotic takes over his brain she said
yes she really enjoyed that idea and she
really went with that you don't so it
was kind of cool it looks fantastic I
think so yeah she's great that way you
know I mean a lot of actors would say no
I wouldn't even think of doing that but
she just embraced here D immediately
yeah
ultimately the editing process is the
final rewrite what did you learn in the
editing room and from any friends and
family screenings that impacted the
finish well I didn't have any friends
and from these FET friends and family
screenings I mean this was kind of
complicated because it moves very fast
you know and I was very aware that we
were in really familiar territory you
know I'm that the basic moves the story
makes are not quite predictable but they
are familiar do you understand what I
mean completely and so we just rocketed
into the thing and kept going really I
mean I had one preview in Los Angeles
and there was a little bit more of an
exploration of the the issue of the
police you know why the police didn't
get involved and stuff like that but the
more scenes that I had in the police
station the more you began a question
their stupidity you know and there was
one or two more scenes with Chloe and
Micah as friends you know
but I mean basically it's just very
little left on the cutting-room floor
really you know sure the uu it's been I
think five years since you made a
feature yeah working the television oh
is it like your first day on set and
were you like oh wow yeah wait we have
more time again wait I'm completely we
have more time again we have we have
something that's understandable again we
have something that the entire crew can
realize there's an ambition it's I mean
making a movie is a bit like you know
you know kind of organizing a heist you
know you say okay
there's a bank in there it's a bunch of
diamonds a bunch of money in there we're
gonna we got six weeks to do this but
we're gonna get in there we're gonna get
that stuff I'm gonna get out of here
it's it's that cut you there's a
communal task I mean that's probably a
bad metaphor the heist Mesmer but
there's a communal task you know and you
can imagine the colors you can imagine
the light and shade of things you could
imagine the cat what the camera
movements should be the whole the whole
kind of the whole light and light and
shade of what you're trying to do you
know at the end six weeks eight weeks
later you've either done or you failed
you know making a television series is
very different you know I think the TV
stuff is more about the writing you know
completely my last thing for you I
really enjoyed the collaboration with
CMAs for the cinematography and in the
look of the film yeah yeah can you sort
of talk about his collaboration and how
you wanted the film to look in the
different parts well I mean the film
starts almost like it could be a it
could be a heartwarming thriller of two
people who are dying of cancer or
something you know it's maybe the
friendship and they get the dog and
she'd find out that Isobel has got
leukemia or some strange disease and you
know that kind of movie it starts almost
like that kind of film it definitely
starts realistically so we have a
palette in mind a shame it's definitely
the palette in mind that started with
realistic photography you know kind of
simple natural light
you know simple observed kind of
realities and then gradually went into a
key risky Road light and shade get to
harshness since the kind of almost a
black-and-white reality you know a movie
that that was a big big reference point
for me after Sheamus was
a film by the unmentionable Roman
Polanski nobody likes to talk about
Roman anymore but anyway he made a movie
called repulsion many years ago in
London and that was almost similar to
this about the entire thing happen in an
apartment you know so that's what we
went for
you